les projets de parcs éoliens en mer
pourraient exploser dans les prochaines
années
les potentiels des vents marins est loin
d'être exploité au maximum
à l'heure actuelle les éoliennes situées
en mer produisent moins 2% de
l'électricité mondiale alors qu'elle
pourrait en fournir assez pour la
consommation de toute la planète selon
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
l'électricité produite par ces parcs
éoliens pour être multiplié par 15 d'ici
20 ans la technologie sont présentes en
europe et de plus en plus fiables et de
moins en moins coûteuse
lisez bien situé en mer pourraient jouer
un grand rôle
remplacer les sources d'électricité
polluantes
[Musique]